[Music]
avengers
assemble for avengers films equals a lot
of content but there are also deleted
scenes out there that change how we see
our favorite heroes so why were they
deleted
where am i it's safe to say steve rogers
also known as captain america goes
through some pretty intense emotions
when he defrosts back into life almost
70 years into the future things aren't
so bad food's a lot better we used to
boil everything one of those being
complete confusion over technology like
wi-fi phone numbers and stan lee
plus we've got free wireless
radio something we didn't get to see in
the theatrical release while the movie
runners decided this scene was a little
redundant and thought that his gym scene
portrayed his frustrations enough this
deleted scene was not only hilarious and
relatable but introduced the character
of beth the waitress
my time has come
what would an avengers movie be without
loki antagonizing other characters in
this deleted scene loki brags to the
other about his plan to take over new
york using the chitari while
simultaneously making fun of their army
much to their dismay our warriors are
fearless the creators felt that the
scene dragged and were a little hesitant
to hint at thanos before the end credit
scene however how cool would it have
been if loki was the one to reveal the
thanos easter egg to us he is the god of
mischief after all missed opportunity we
say yes your alpaca ate them all
an end game the first time we see tony
stark pepper and their daughter morgan
is when the avengers decide to pay them
a visit at their cabin but originally
there was much more to their post blip
introduction this adorable deleted scene
between the family was removed because
the plot hadn't gotten to them yet but
this domestic bliss could have been such
a beautiful moment to let fans see how
truly happy the starks were and what
tony stark was truly putting on the line
by participating in the final battle not
to mention we also learn about gerald
the alpaca hey bruce
you gotta fight
this is just what loki wants
hulk's rampage inside the shield
helicarrier was nothing short of
destructive but we didn't see all of it
in the final cut in the extended scene
there's a moment where we see natasha
also known as black widow hiding from
her fellow avenger with an original run
time of three hours this scene was cut
for time but perhaps keeping in more
moments between the two characters would
have made their brief romance a little
less shocking and a little more
meaningful by the way did you catch the
actor behind cgi hulk in the deleted
moment i need your help it's nice to be
nated it's dangerous i'd be disappointed
if it wasn't thor's vision scene where
he discovers ultron has the mind stone
is intense but not as intense as it was
originally meant to be this deleted
scene shows thor taking a visit to the
water of sights where he is possessed by
a norn in order to prompt the vision
this was meant to give us all the info
on the infinity stone and hint at the
infinity stone storyline
something that could have made all the
difference to thor's character arc but
the filmmakers had no choice but to opt
for the more concise but less
informative version in order to save
time captain america saved my life
remember the cap deleted scene where he
met the waitress beth well the
filmmakers had no choice but to delete
this eye contact moment between the two
because of their previous decision this
character and look was this close to
introducing a potential love triangle
between peggy and beth who knows what
would have happened if they had decided
to keep beth in the film and in his life
are you a big guy that gets all little
or a little guy that blows up large
following hulk's big shield rampage we
see him crash into a warehouse where he
meets a very nonchalant security guard
while the final cut was more of a
comedic relief moment well then son
you've got a condition this deleted
scene shows a conversation between the
two that really prompts bruce to look
inward and have a moment of reflection a
scene that brought a lot of clarity to
his struggle with being the hulk i know
where i can do the most good but it's
where i can do the most time but the
12-page script was just a little too
long for the filmmakers
we're at war
and he thinks about superheroes maria
hill may not be an avenger but she plays
a huge role in the mcu as a shield agent
in fact she was originally supposed to
be featured in the opening avengers
scene that foreshadows a destroyed new
york it was cut because the audience
didn't respond to it as well in the test
screening but the scene could have
established maria as more of a main
character in the film instead of the
more minor role she played
that little witch is messing with your
mind hulk's character development was
against sacrifice during his age of
ultron rampage instigated by scarlet
witch in a deleted scene it featured a
much longer version of the rampage where
she struggled with his transformation
showing us the restraint bruce had and
his need to be better than an
uncontrolled hulk instead we got tony
saving the day with his hulkbuster
you're jealous you're not getting a
dress yep there's a world and avengers
storyline where wanda gets to keep her
brother quicksilver an alternate version
of the battle of sokovia was actually
filmed where quicksilver survives and
even returns to the new york avengers
facility with wanda vision war machine
and falcon it demands me to come to the
church it was filmed just in case disney
and marvel didn't agree with their
decision pietro surviving would have
changed everything for wanda including
the spin-off series one division would
wanda still have become evil who knows
wanna know a secret there was an entire
endgame battle sequence that was left
out of the theatrical release the russo
brothers said in order to create a
timeout from the battle some of the key
characters slipped into the mirror
dimension in order to have a
conversation and then they were going to
go back in the field but they decided to
cut it when the test audiences weren't
feeling it the moment could have
provided the audience with so much more
context as to how the avengers could
truly assemble luckily the scene is on
disney plus now and you couldn't have
jumped out of the plane before you
crashed it even the avengers filmmakers
liked to have fun which is why they shot
this meta moment between roadie and cap
roadie brings to light a question marvel
fans have been asking themselves forever
why didn't captain america just jump out
of the hydroplane before it crashed when
he was retrieving the tesseract but they
didn't want to draw any more attention
to the infinity stones at this point no
matter how hilarious it would be to the
audience god get it together we see a
completely different thor in endgame one
that goes through a lot of healing to
get back to the god of thunder in a
deleted scene between him and rocket
raccoon and asgard we get more of his
feelings of depression and defeat a
moment that would have made fans
sympathize and relate to him more even
if he was using a fountain as a toilet
you're embarrassing they had to cut it
in the end but it premiered at comic-con
you wanna come work for me putts
i'm a little tied up in futures right
now tony stark getting to meet his
father howard in the past was a very
bittersweet moment but the filmmakers
had the opportunity to build on their
connection even more with an extended
version the scene could have given
audiences a whole other layer to their
connection and show just how much howard
actually cared for his son
if
running's a plan
as far as you want
if this deleted scene between natasha
and bruce had been included then maybe
their romantic relationship would make a
little more sense in the scene natasha
actively tried to convince bruce to run
away and live in peace together but
bruce was too caught up in his recent
rampage to believe her there was an
opportunity to use this scene as a way
to really show natasha's feelings for
bruce
i adore you even without these deleted
scenes every avengers movie is
jam-packed with multiple character and
plot story lines that push the
boundaries of theatrical release run
times that means it's understandable
they'd have to cut a lot from what we
see on screen but who wouldn't love some
extra banter between rocket and thor
what deleted scene do you wish was
included in the films let us know below
thanks for watching